McDonald to ask the Scottish government
in light of the recent analysis by the
international monetary fund which
predicts the UK UK's economy performance
in 2023 will be the worst amongst the
G20 economies while assessment has been
made of the potential impact of this in
Scotland government secretary Newbury
thank you president officer at the
forecast by the IMF for the UK economy
to be the worst performing in the G20 is
a shocking indictment of the UK
government's mismanagement of the
economy which undeniably has an impact
on the Scottish economy global economic
conditions are challenging and the
Scottish government is doing everything
possible within its limited powers to
support households and businesses
through the current cost crisis and to
grow and transform the economy in a way
that delivers fairer Greener Prosperity
however the UK government's
mismanagement of the economy alongside
the economic damage of brexit risks
harming our International
competitiveness and holding back our
ambitious program of work Gordon
McDonald
I think the cabinet secretary for that
answer this analysis by the IMF just
serves to underline the ongoing
detrimental impact which Westminster
control continues to have on Scotland's
economy and the people of Scotland are
paying the price experts are now
predicting that the UK's withdrawal from
the EU is costing millions of workers
1300 pounds a year in Lost income does
the cabinet secretary share my concern
that the Tories and labor at Westminster
seem determined to press ahead with
imposing their disastrous brexit on
Scotland no matter the economic
consequences and does he agree that the
best way to ensure our economy and
communities can flourish is by rejoining
the EU as an independent country
[Applause]
dependence
Independence and rejoining the EU gives
us the powers we need to take advantage
of the rich economic opportunities we
have and where we are currently being
held up by UK in action the EU the US
have invested in their economies putting
them at competitive Advantage for taking
advantage of the green industrial future
we need Independence and the powers that
that gives us to make sure we can take
advantage of our Rich opportunity here
in Scotland question number five Stephen
Curry
this Scottish government how many
apprenticeship places it will commit to
funding this financial year Minister
Green Day present officer modern
apprenticeships are a vital resource for
employers to invest in their Workforce
and for the people to develop their
skills invest in the skills across
people's lifetimes is critical to our
future productivity and success my
priority and that this government is for
high quality apprenticeships that
provide sustainable jobs and careers
support not transition to Net Zero
skills development Scotland have already
issued contracts for 39 000 modern
Apprentice is currently in training
we're working closely in intensely with
skills development Scotland there is one
effective way to the expectations of
Learners and employers and I expect
skills development scholarly to begin
finalizing contracts for new modern
apprenticeship starts imminently Stephen
King here's what the Scottish training
Federation have said in the past hour
three thousand apprentices due to start
a modern apprenticeship this month have
been left in limbo due to the current
freeze on funding for new apprenticeship
places and around a thousand employers
who had planned to hire these
apprentices have had to put their
recruitment plans on hold that's after
they surveyed a thousand employers
planning to take on apprentices now I
know the SNP are consumed by their
internal Wars but why should thousands
of young people be paying a price for
the smps incompetence and distraction
for months the SMP have been denying
there's a freeze on a friendship so
there is a freeze there was a freeze
last summer there's a freeze now and I
welcome the minister we have the
question please and I know
I I welcome the minister to his new post
I know how passionate he is about
apprenticeships so will he turn the page
on the mess his predecessor left him and
fix this mess today Minister briefly
please
to be very significant budget challenges
we're facing which the UK government's
mismanagement the economy has much to do
with and the change of ministers it was
entirely reasonable to pause temporarily
the issuing of contracts for new starts
whilst we looked at the the bigger
picture but I'm pleased to tell the
chamber we are about to green light that
process and despite the huge budgetary
challenges we're facing I would
anticipate the number involved will be
in line with 22-23. thank you Minister
that concludes the general questions uh
the next item of business is first
ministers questions and I call it
question number one Douglas Ross thank
you presiding officer rules of this
Parliament to prevent me from asking
crucial questions about the Scandal over
the s p finances so I cannot dwell on
this here but I do want to give the
first Minister an opportunity to be
transparent with my opening question
today
because last night the first Minister
became the smp's treasurer so while this
is still a party matter it is also now a
government matter if the first minister
is compromised if his hands are tied if
the party of government is about to go
bankrupt or if he himself may become
involved in the police investigation
and yesterday the deputy first Minister
said this
going forward the governance of the
party needs to be about transparency
openness and people should be able to
question about the accounts and we agree
and believe that there are legitimate
questions that the Scottish public
deserves to know answers to so in the
interests of transparency well Hamza
Yusuf agreed to make a statement to
Parliament on the financial Scandal
engulfing the party of government here
in Scotland
um what
are we in terms of standing standing as
first minister questions is the
opportunity to put questions to the
first Minister that fall within the
responsibilities of the first Minister
as first Minister and of course the
responsibilities of his government and
therefore I am not entirely clear that
that question has met the requirements
of sending orders and I I'm looking at
the first minister to see if he's
anything he wishes to add to what I've
said Christmas I am happy to answer the
question I know there are some of course
serious issues for the party that I lead
the SNP to address I'm not going to shy
away from that presiding officer that's
why in my very first act as SNP leader
attending my very first national
executive committee I'm pleased that we
got agreement from that committee they
elected the body that oversees the party
that is elected by our members to a
review into transparency and governance
and not only into transparency and
governance review but one that has
external input particularly on the
issues of financial oversight so of
course that is an important job an
important role for me to take forward as
leader of the SNP but let me also say
that what I am doing what the government
I lead to what we are doing collectively
is focusing relentlessly on the day job
that is why in the first few weeks of
being first Minister I know double I
didn't just double the fuel insecurity
fund I made sure we tripled the fuel and
security for now I know Douglas Ross
won't want to talk about that because of
course it lays bare the harm the Tory
cost of living crisis is doing to
households up and down the country
that's also why in the first few weeks
this first Minister I made sure I
focused I was suspend proceedings first
Minister please
okay we will resume proceedings please
continue first Minister Douglas will be
pleased it was me that got interrupted
uh for for once uh no doubt this is why
in the first few weeks as first Minister
I was when it's 15 million pounds for
school age child care targeted towards
the lowest income households 25 million
pounds additional 25 million pounds to
support the just transition additional
funding to support GP practices that are
in are areas of highest deprivation 25
million pounds to be able to buy back a
long lease empty properties for the
social renter sector so these are
priorities for me the priorities of the
Scottish people and while I take my
responsibility as leader of the SNP
extremely seriously I and the government
that I lead will be focused relentlessly
on the priorities of the Scottish people
yeah
talk to straws
the the first words in the first
Minister when he stood up where he was
happy to answer the question and then
basically refused to do so because I was
simply asking it for a statement and
transparency and I do think it is needed
from the first Minister because the
secrecy it must end but I'm going to
move on to one of the matters of
substance that the first Minister should
be focusing his attention on instead of
his huge distraction within the party
last year an SMP government agency
introduced guidelines that encourage
more lenient sentences on under 25 even
in some of the worst crimes the Justice
secretary was just asked about this in
the session for FM cues so can I ask the
first Minister does he fully support the
policy which was brought forward for
consultation when he was just a
secretary
first Minister because here this was of
course a very important issue indeed and
while I won't comment on individual
sentencing decisions it would be right
for me to do so as a first Minister let
me just clarify some issues around the
sentencing guidelines which I think are
really really important I heard Angela
Constance make these points in response
to a question earlier on sensing
guidelines are of course rightly
entirely the responsibility of the
independent sentencing Council decisions
about whether to approve those
guidelines are of course for the high
court now the the cabinet secretary the
new cabinet secretary for justice and
home Affairs she has written to the
chair of the sentencing Council to
discuss that important Mark and that
letter knows that she will discuss how
the council plans to keep those
published guidelines under review but it
is also important that when it comes to
decisions on sentencing not only are
they rightly for the independent
Judiciary but also that they are
evidence-based and for anybody who is
read that sentence I'm assuming Douglas
Ross has done so you can see a
comprehensive guideline that is
evidence-based in terms of its
sentencing of young people and the last
thing I would say planning officer on
that instant guideline of course
notwithstanding all of the good that is
in there that is very very clear that
there is no bar on imposing a custodial
sentence on a young person aware of
course judicially consider that to be
appropriate but that must be a decision
not for the first Minister not for
government ministers neither I would say
for opposition colleagues it is a
decision rightly for the independent
tradition
a few weeks ago my party and almost
everyone in Scotland was outreached at
the case of a 13 year old girl who was
raped at a park in dalkeith her attacker
Sean Hogg was found guilty of rape
he didn't go to prison
all he had to do was carry out 270 hours
of unpaid work
the judge said if Hogg had committed the
crime when he was over 25 he would now
be behind bars so that confirms that the
problem here is the sentencing
guidelines that were introduced it's
very clear that the smp's justice system
is broken so will the first Minister fix
it
before I asked the first minister to
respond I would remind everybody in the
chamber that this actually is a live
case and therefore any reference there
too should be made with Extreme Caution
first Minister
and with that caveat in police planning
officer let me also say that my reaction
to that case I can understand why people
do have concern but I must go back to
the central point here that sentencing
decisions are of course rightly for the
independent courts and the independent
Judiciary the Lord president reminded me
of that when he made some remarks on the
public record when I attended the court
of session to give my oath as the first
minister of Scotland and I committed to
upholding the independence of the
Judiciary a responsibility I take with
the utmost seriousness I also read the
very distressing account of the 13 the
victim who was 30 year old at the time
and also heard from her family on the
public statements that have been made in
anybody I think everybody frankly that
would sympathize with the strong
feelings of the victim and it's
important to say at this stage talking
in the general not about that specific
case of course that 98 of all of those
who are convicted of rape were convicted
of rape between 2018 and 2021 did
receive a custodial sentence so it is
important that we continue to give the
Judiciary the Independence that they
have it's important to have that
separation between government and
Judiciary but what I would say is that
in the later that Angela Constance was
sent to the sentencing Council to the
Lord Justice clerk they want if you
would like to discuss and the government
would like to discuss the issues around
how these sentencing guidelines are kept
under review and I take the point that
Douglas Ross makes there is clearly a
public interest in that sentencing
kindly
the first Minister mentioned that he had
seen the comments from the victim and
her family and this is all in the public
domain and is very legitimate to raise
here in the chamber the grandfather of
the victim said this with this new
ruling they've got any person under 25
can go out and do any kind they want
however horrendous it may be and there's
a good chance that they will get a
community Payback
and the Survivor of this rape said this
when I was told he had been found guilty
I felt a wave of emotions I didn't know
how to react
I cried I think I cried with relief
now it makes me think why did I even
bother reporting the rape in the first
place
she continued whoever is in charge of
the justice system needs to sort this
out
you see you care about victims like me
but how can a serial rapist receive 270
hours of community Payback
her final line was why is it okay to
rape anyone and not go to jail the first
Minister seems to be healing 98 of
people convicted of going to prison it
should it must be 100 of rapists
convicted of that crime going to prison
so let me repeat the words of the victim
as my question to the first minister
why is it okay for anyone to rape
someone and not go to jail first
minister so again speaking in the
general not a bit of specific case uh I
agree with the sentiment that if
somebody commits rape they should go to
jail I believe that but of course I also
believe very very firmly that is up it
is up to the independent Judiciary is up
to judges it's up to those in the high
court to make a decision about what the
appropriate punishment is for an
individual for the crime that they have
committed and let me again just refer
back to this instant guideline which is
of course the central issue that Douglas
Ross raises with me the guidelines make
it clear that as well as looking at
issues that are in Rehabilitation
consideration of sentencing for young
people under 25 they make it very very
clear in that sentencing guideline the
other factors including punishment
protection of the public and expressing
a strong disapproval of offending
Behavior should also be taken into
account so the courts can still even
with this guideline faith and pose a
custodial sentence on a young person if
they consider that to be appropriate in
light of all the facts but I take what
what has been said by the victim and her
grandfather very very seriously indeed
and that's why we are looking to improve
the justice system when it comes to
particularly those individuals
particularly women who are often the
victims of sexual offenses and of course
uh rape and we'll shortly introduce our
Criminal Justice Reform Bill which seeks
to make those changes to the court
system to the justice system in order to
be able to improve the experience and
improve outcomes of justice for victims
of sexual offenses and rape and I hope
it will get support from right across
the chamber
I call it question number two and a
server bringing officer on Tuesday Yusuf
tried to convince the country that he
represented a fresh start 16 years of
command and control financial
mismanagement and a complete lack of
transparency this isn't just how they
governed their party it's how they
govern the country just one example the
ongoing Ferry crisis 200 million pounds
over budget with no ferries in sight and
last week I was in the western house and
I heard directly from people about the
consequences of this failure canceled
ferries meaning missed cancer
appointments lack of supplies coming in
produce not getting out and businesses
going to the wall in 2017 the then SMP
Minister for transport and the island
said resolving the Western house ferry
crisis was a priority
six years on they're still waiting and
it's got worse so can I ask the first
Minister who was that incompetent
transport Minister and where are they
now
first minister
can I say that I I of course recognize
the challenges that our Ferry services
those are those who rely on our faith
services are Island communities have
suffered in the last few weeks
particularly given the Easter tourism
season but let me also speak very
clearly to those Island communities that
we understand not just their frustration
but we are taking action to ensure that
we bolster the ferry Network Services
that's why this government has bought
and deployed an additional vessel in the
MV lock freestyle that's why we
chartered the mvu arrow to provide
additional resilience and capacity
that's why we commissioned two new
vessels for Ayla that's why we
commissioned two new vessels for the
little Minch Roots that's why we
progressed key investments in ports and
harbors that's why we've confirmed
additional Revenue funding for the
operation of local Authority Ferry
services and that's why of course we are
looking forward to the MV Alfred and
provided additional funding at to calmac
for the M3 alvarid Alfred to provide
additional resilience not just for the
next few weeks but for the next nine
months so this is of course a very
serious matter raised by Anna sawar but
we are a government that is taking
action to ensure that we have resilience
on our ferries Network
I think I'm sorry that was the great
example of what's become typical of this
leadership in the last three weeks
comical Ali everything's fine while the
house burns down behind us Island
communities will not believe those
excuses from the minister the first
Minister and this government are totally
out of touch six years ago Hamza use of
his transport Minister media promised to
fix this but this SNP government has
failed to get a grip and its Financial
mismanagement has cost us hundreds of
millions of pounds but it's also cost
people on the island dearly to the
impact on the local economy has been
devastating one report has estimated
that the loss of the law
cost nearly 50 000 pounds a day that's
almost double the average annual salary
on the islands as one business put it no
Ferry means no income no jobs no people
and the businesses in us have asked the
Scottish government to compensate them
for their losses last year transport
Scotland took millions of pounds in
fines from calmac because of the lack of
services so will the first Minister
commit to compensating Islanders and at
the very least passed on the find that
the government have collected from
karlmac to the people affected by this
crisis first Minister
can I say I'll look at any proposals
that are suggested by anybody across
this chamber including the one that I
saw a war just mentioned there but look
I completely accept and and I'm
unequivocal in saying that the
government understands and regrets any
delays and disruptions that have
impacted our Island communities what
doesn't help Ireland communities there's
sound bites and really easy sound bites
from anastar are not in any attempt to
provide any solutions but selling
personal attacks alone comically that's
not going to help those in our Island
communities uh one single bit what will
help our Island community is of course
is delivering members members members
major vessels six new major vessels to
serve Scotland's Ferry Network by 2026
that's the priority for this government
and let's look at the facts because of
course there has been disruption I'm not
denying that at all but in 2022 there
were 170
000 scheduled sailings across the Chiefs
Network and around 6.6 of those were
canceled over half of those were
canceled due to weather related issues
and around 1.1 percent of the total
scheduled sailings were due to technical
issues so the vast majority of scheduled
ceilings do take place when they are
meant to the ferry service network we
should also be well bolster in terms of
its resilience and that's why I look
forward to the Charter of the MV MV
Alfred coming on board in the coming
days so whatever else I will end where I
started any sensible suggestions from
across the opposition from across this
chamber it will be listened to by this
government and it's not working the
harsh reality is the island communities
just don't believe them Island
communities feel completely let down and
they've heard these excuses for years
and they can't wait more years of
government failure this is impacting the
lives of Islanders right now businesses
are failing right now millions of pounds
are being lost right now exports are
stuck on the island right now and people
need support right now and that's why
they need that compensation scheme but
presenting officer this is no fresh
start Hamza used to have served in
government for over a decade a failed
transport minister with hundreds of
millions of pounds wasted on ferries
that never failed it failed Justice
secretary with millions of pounds wasted
and bought prosecutions and Court delays
a failed Health secretary with over 300
million pounds wasted on delayed
discharge while people wait to get
life-saving treatment and just three
weeks and a failed first Minister bogged
down in Scandal unable to lead and
completely out of touch with the
priorities of the people of Scotland so
can I ask the acting SMP Treasurer why
huge Scots keep paying the price for SMP
failure first producer
can I see uh once again to Anna sabar we
are acting though that's why the MV
Alfred an additional vessel which we
have helped to fund calmac Force coming
on board in the next few days so that is
tangible action which will make a
difference to our fairy networks right
here and right now and he says that the
people of Scotland don't trust us he was
in The Western Isles can I remind him
the West Niles has an SMP MP under SNP
MSP to the people of The Western Isles
absolutely do trust them members members
we need to hear that he says
that we haven't been getting on with the
job well I'm afraid that people in
Scotland disagree with them when I stood
here on Tuesday and announced and
articulated our policy perspective I'm
delighted it got support from the suvo
it got support some of the policies I
announced got support from Dr Liz
Cameron the the chief executive of the
Scottish Chambers of Commerce from
transport Scotland
transformed Scotland forgive me and
relation to the pilot in the terms of
the pilot for Peak rail fairs being
abolished from the Scottish whiskey
Association from the chartered Institute
of housing in Scotland from the Scottish
empty homes partnership from crisis
Scotland from reform Scotland from the
poverty Alliance from stop climate chaos
from Parkinson's UK so this is a time
for new leadership of course which I'm
delighted to bring to this government a
time for a fresh start the people of
Scotland recognize that maybe it's time
Scottish labor should recognize that too
I call question number three Maggie
Chapman
thank you presiding officer to ask the
first Minister whether he will provide
an update on what recent engagement the
Scottish government has had with the UK
government regarding the proposed
development of the Rose Bank oil and gas
field in light of the Scottish
government's draft energy strategy and
just transition plan chrismanism
licensing exploration and production of
the offshore oil and gas sector of
course does remain reserved regrettably
to the UK government the Scottish
government is clear the unlimited
extraction of fossil fuels is not
consistent with our climate obligations
it's not the solution to the energy
price crisis meeting our energy security
needs or indeed ensuring a just
transition for our oil and gas workers
as North Sea production inevitably
declines that's why we need a new plan
for Scotland's Energy System the draft
energy strategy strategy and just
transition plan seeks to do this the
Scottish government is absolutely
committed to adjust transition and
ensuring we take workers with us on that
important journey to Net Zero and we
won't do to the Northeast what Thatcher
did to Mining and stealing communities
right across Scotland Mackie Chapman
so for that response while recognizing
that licensing is reserved the draft
energy strategy and just transition plan
sets out a position that in order to
support the fastest possible and most
effective just transition there should
be a presumption against new exploration
for oil and gas
since the draft plan was published the
U.N Secretary General has said our world
needs climate action on all fronts
everything everywhere all at once
ceasing all licensing or funding of new
oil and gas stopping any expansion of
existing oil and gas reserves and
shifting subsidies from fossil fuels to
a Just Energy transition whether it's
rosebank today or other proposals to
drill tomorrow does the first Minister
agree that a just transition on a
livable livable planet depends on our
firm commitment to a fossil fuel free
future fresmanism I do agree that we
want and we should all want a fossil
fuel free future and I do agree on that
delivering on our climate obligations is
of course an absolute Priority One of
the first things I did I think in my
second official visit as first Minister
I went to the northeast of Scotland and
I spoke to those who are absolutely
committed to that just transition that
just transition particularly in the
Northeast I want the northeast of
Scotland to be the next zero Capital not
just of Europe I wanted to be the next
zero capital of the world I believe it
has the potential to do so and so
Michael Chapman is absolutely right that
first and foremost we have to make sure
that any decisions that are taken by the
UK government must be taken in relation
to our climate obligations we want the
UK government to strengthen its climate
climate compatibility checkpoint we've
asked for tougher more robust climate
tests secondly we should ensure that
they align with our energy security
needs and thirdly and this is really
Central and I believe Maggie Chapman
will absolutely agree with this we must
take the workers of the north east with
us as I've already said we will never do
to the Northeast what Margaret Thatcher
did to our Mining and steel communities
we will not decimate sectors we will not
we will not leave a single worker on the
scrap people that's why I'm continued to
that's why I will continue to invest in
the just transition and accelerate that
just transition as quickly as we
possibly can supplementary Liam care
very grateful presiding officer first
Minister new exploration and production
in the North Sea would protect over 70
000 Scottish jobs it would help our
energy security and it would have a
positive impact on emissions rather than
offshoring our responsibilities
therefore will the first Minister
re-examine the plans in his threadbare
energy strategy to close the North Sea
or will he continue to be dictated to by
a cabal of green msps
that of course is not what is in the
draft draft strategy but of course if we
were to unleash and truly unlock the
green economy then we are talking about
tens of thousands of jobs over the next
couple of decades and we want to take
the workers of the Northeast in
particular uh with us on that Johnny but
what a cheek what a cheek that Liam care
stands there and talks about Scottish
jobs when it comes to energy when his
party when the the party that he belongs
to the UK government have continued to
block have continued to delay have
continued to dither when it comes to the
Scottish cluster and the acorn project
which they have refused refused to give
permission to and have relegated to
track two so let me just say once again
the Tories can never be trusted when it
comes to protecting Scottish jobs
and supplementary Ferguson
there's lady officer here in Scotland
and the UK we will need and continue to
need and rely on gas
for decades to come
uh the gas is imported in many cases
from the USA but their gas is produced
with over four times four times the
carbon emissions of rosebank therefore
does the first Minister agree with me
that sacrificing development of our own
gas resource would not only decimate
tens of thousands of Highly skilled
well-paid jobs in a form of economic
masochism advocated by the wine bar
revolutionaries in the green party
but also but also make climate change
worse actually worse not better I
before the first military service before
the first Minister responds I would
remind all members of the requirement to
treat each other with purchasing and
respect first minister
I've Got a Feeling addictive playing off
so that's not the first time you've had
to tell off your brother uh uh one one
of the specs but let me let me uh
actually and some point of agreement uh
with Berger's viewing say that nobody in
the Scottish government certainly uh
nobody uh that I've heard certainly not
just not in Scottish government but also
in the green party have said uh that
extraction has to stop uh tomorrow
because we understand that they're just
transition means that we have to take
the workers of the Northeast with us and
of course the point is that it's a just
transition it has to be just and that's
why we believe that that of course uh
that we Excel we must accelerate that
just transition with further investment
uh in those non-fossil fuel uh
Alternatives what I would say is the
independent research based on industry
projections found that production in the
north city will be around about a third
of 2019 Levels by 2035 so we know it is
a declining based and hence why we have
to make sure that we are accelerating at
that just transition and meanwhile as of
2019 only 16 of the oil and gas coming
into Scotland including imports from
Norway and Beyond is consumed in
Scotland so reducing our energy
consumption while ramping up our energy
generation capabilities through
Renewables through hydrogen will mean
that next year of Scotland will not only
be less relying on importing oil and gas
but hopefully be our net exporter of
cleaner and Greener energy to the rest
of the UK and Beyond question number
four Audrey Network
thank you to ask the first minister in
light of his recent visit to the port of
Aberdeen what engagement he's had with
the business Community since taking
office first
resetting the relationship with business
is a core priority for this government
on Tuesday I say to plans to agree a new
deal for businesses and the introduction
of a new group co-chaired by the cabinet
secretary for the well-being economy for
fair work and energy that will Explore
her government can better support our
businesses and communities using all the
policy levers we have to our hands
during my visit to the port of Aberdeen
and it's 25 million pounds as I've
already referenced to be invested for
the just transition away from oil and
gas this was the first of many meetings
I have planned as part of an extensive
program of Engagement with business and
industry leaders across all of
Scotland's sectors to identify those
priority or areas of both challenge but
also opportunity and later today I will
also meet with the main business
organizations to personally reiterate my
commitment to this new working
relationship and how we can deliver on
our mission of a fairer Greener and
indeed a growing well-being economy for
all of Scotland's people Audrey nickel
Minister for his response the Scottish
country commitment to agree and you deal
for business has received an extremely
positive response from the business
community and we all agree it is
absolutely vital we work together
constructively to develop our well-being
economy given the substantial pressures
many businesses are facing from rising
costs and a disastrous brexit it's clear
urgent and sustained action is needed to
maximize the support available to them
so can the first Minister say any more
about the steps the Scottish government
is taking to ensure it can best support
our businesses using the full policy
levers it has at its disposal and does
he agree that the full powers that with
who Powers over our economy resting with
this Parliament we would be much better
placed to support our businesses to
thrive first minister of course we would
absolutely and I can hear groans and
years from the Scottish conservatives
well let's let's read what the chairman
of the obr said about the Empire impact
of brexit on the UK economy said it was
on the same magnitude as covet as a
covet pandemic an energy priced crisis
and the the corporate pandemic has had
and he said also of course in fact to
the Center for European reform said that
they found that brexit has caused the UK
a staggering 33 billion in Lost trades
so this is not just the opinion of the
SNP LED Scottish government it's the
opinion of those experts in the economy
who are saying that brexit has seriously
impacted trade in the UK and of course
trade here in Scotland too and
businesses are the backbone of the
economy I'm a proud son of a small
business owner and that's why the New
Deal for business which I articulated in
our policy perspectives on Tuesday is so
so important it's crucial and through
the Scottish budget we responded to
businesses biggest ask and non-domestic
Race by freezing the poundage in 23 24
that's estimated to save ratepayers
308 million pounds so we'll continue to
use the powers of of devolution that we
have to the absolute maximum effect to
grow and transform our well-being
economy however I agree we need
significantly increased policy leavers
to ensure that Scotland will be
wealthier will be fairer will be greener
and of course the well-being of our
people is enhanced until we do that I'm
afraid that the Scottish conservatives
will continue to have the levers that we
can see they use to harm our people and
to harm business and trade here in
Scotland a supplementary doctors
thank you
thank you because I know sir
connectivity between the port of
Aberdeen and the Freeport and committee
will be vital for the Northeast economy
so we're the first Minister grow a
backbone stand up to the greens and
fully duel the a-96 as promised first
minister
just to the to the heart of the
conservatives hypocrisy the demand we go
further on tackling the climate
emergency anything we do including a
review for example of section of the a96
for climate compatibility the opposed so
it doesn't matter what the Scottish
government tries to do to ensure that we
tackle the climate emergency so we leave
a cleaner Planet a sustainable planet
for our future Generations the
conservatives were always always
opposable let me say very clearly that
we are absolutely committed of course
the drilling of the A9 but also the a96
Inverness to learn and there and bypass
and I've said already through my good
friend forever suing that will bring
forward a timetable on that as soon as
we possibly can
question number five Donald Cameron
to ask the first Minister whether he
will provide an update on the Scottish
government's plans for highly protected
Marine areas following the end of its
public consultation first Minister our
initial consultation on highly protected
meaning areas closed on Monday it's only
right of course that we do take some
time to carefully consider all the
responses and there has been a
substantial number of responses before
we set out our next steps as I say
especially given the strength of views
that we all know have been expressed on
this issues on this issue our seas of
course must remain a source of
prosperity for the nation especially in
those remote Coastal and Island
communities it's vital that those
communities do help shape the creation
of these areas which is why we chose to
consult very early on in this process my
officials have held over 40 meetings
relating to the process and my colleague
Maddie McAllen will continue to engage
directly with Coastal and Island
communities before we decide our next
steps together to be clear no sites have
been selected this will not begin until
we've considered the consultation
feedback and until that engagement is
complete and we are determined to ensure
that as many voices as possible are
heard in this process Donald Cameron
earlier this week the first Minister
said that hpma should not be imposed on
communities that don't want them first
Minister not one community in the
highlands and Islands wants these not
one we all acknowledge the need to
protect our marine environment but these
proposals will devastate Coastal
communities and threaten their very way
of life particularly the fishing sector
it's no wonder this policy has been
compared to the clearances people
cleared off the land and cleared off the
sea
given the anger this has caused given
the widespread opposition to these plans
including from many in his own party and
given he wants to be first Minister for
the whole country will he now scrap
these plans once and for all and start
again
well the point is that there are no
plans yet there is a consultation we do
not have set set sites we do not have
set criteria yet so what we want to do
is at a very early stage Inception stage
in fact work with Coastal communities
Island communities our fishing
communities because ultimately I do
believe there is agreement on the
outcome the outcome that we all want is
a sustainable marine environment what we
want of course is our is our fishing
industry and our fishing are seized to
be sustainable for the future we want
that industry to continue but we can
only do that of course if the marine
environment is sustainable so I do
believe there's an agreement there and
of course our fishing communities our
Island communities our Coastal
communities have often been at the
Forefront of that effort around
sustainability so we want to work with
them we want to engage with them all
that being said I will reiterate what I
said on Tuesday that this government
will not that stimul will not impose
upon any Community a policy that they
are vehemently opposed to so my my
colleague Marie Maddie McAllen well of
course engage with those Island
communities with those Coastal
communities and we will analyze those
responses very carefully but for all of
those who have expressed their
opposition to highly protected Marine
areas and let me say that we are willing
to engage we are willing to to listen
and let's hope we get to the agreed
outcomes together supplementary Kenneth
Gibson thank you presiding officers
that's the first Minister agree with the
no take Zone in umlash Bay has a no
adverse impact whatsoever and indeed has
shown that conservation can help to
revitalize our fishing sector and that
identifying potentially highly protected
Marine area sites would allow more
effective direct engagement with
concerned Fishers and communities
absolutely right I mean far from having
any adverse impact it's shown us the
benefit for both the marine environment
and the people who rely on it and I go
back to that point I think a very good
example in relation to lamb lash Bay
where it was the community that wanted
that note-take zone so this is goes to
the central point here that we will work
with communities hopefully to get to the
outcomes that we all agree on which is a
sustainable marine environment and based
on studies that were coordinated by the
community group adlam lash Bay it's been
noted that sense protection commercially
import important species such as the
king scallop such as the European
Lobster they've increased in size
they've increased in age they've
increased in density so the 2008
designation of the Lamb lash Bay no take
Zone off the coast of Aaron as I say was
a result of campaigning by the local
community and I think that is a good
model for us to take forward our our
work around highly protected
millionaires supplementing
an officer earlier this week Orton
Island's Council joined counterparts in
Shetland in The Western Isles invoicing
the strongest possible opposition to the
government's plans for highly protected
Marine areas given the potential impact
on island communities on the same day
the first Minister announced welcome if
long overdue you turns on his deposit
return scheme and alcohol advertising
sanctions can I therefore urge him not
to spend months defending the
indefensible and confirm in light of the
significant and growing opposition in
coastal and Island communities that his
government will now rethink its plans to
arbitrarily designate 10 of Scottish
Waters at hpmas by 2026. first minister
the MacArthur will be well aware when I
was transporting Islands Minister I
introduced and brought forward Island
proofing it's something I believe in to
my very core and therefore we will not
impose upon any Community Ireland or
otherwise a policy that they vehemently
oppose let's analyze the consultation
responses let's agree on the outcomes I
think there is generally broad agreement
on the outcome that we want to have a
marine environment that is sustainable
we want to have a fishing sector that is
sustainable in the long term and of
course protecting our biodiversity helps
us with that outcome so we will continue
to engage I will continue to engage
personally Marie McAllen will also
engage personally she will no doubt
travel right across the country
including two orkney and Shetland to
meet with those who have expressed
concerns and together I hope we can get
to a place where we all agree on the
outcome and then of course move forward
to protect our marine environment to
make it more sustainable for the future
question number six Rosie Grant
to ask the first Minister what immediate
action the Scottish government will take
to improve the situation regarding Ferry
services across the highlands and
Islands in light of recent reports of
unprecedented disruption first minister
as I've already said in response to a
question from Anna Saba I do recognize
this is a significant impact that delays
that disruption does have during the
annual overhaul program and it's
regrettably had on our Island
communities we know our own communities
of course rely on these Lifeline
Services not just of course individuals
but businesses uh too and I'm committed
to investing in our Ferry services
indeed we're going to be delivering six
new major vessels to serve Scott's Ferry
Network by 2026 it's a priority for me
and for the government that I lead we've
already procured MV Lok Visa previously
chartered the AMV arrow and of course we
look forward to shortly welcoming the MV
Alfred and service providing some
additional resilience to the network in
the meantime we'll continue to press
calmac to consider all options to
minimize the impact on communities and
indeed businesses and I know the
minister for transport is engaging very
closely on this issue he's held
resilience calls with calmac with
transport Scotland in light of the
latest disruption and he has proactively
engaged directly with local stakeholders
with our operators and cmail on
improving reliability and resilience
right across the network Roger Grant
the transport Minister refused to take
responsibility for the ferry crisis and
he also refused compensation payments to
local businesses who are actually going
to the war because of these very
failures
now that constituents in U.S are well
have no Mainland services from Sunday
that's two days time as the first
Minister going to do the same or does he
want to tell us what emergency provision
he's going to put in place has he asked
the mot for help and what compensation
is he going to give to businesses that
will close as a result of this first
Minister again I've always said in
response to the question from manasawa
that we will consider the issues around
compensation and what more we can do to
support businesses when there is
disruption but I don't agree with the
premise of our question I know that
Kevin Stewart has been directly involved
in engaging with calmac but also with
the island communities that have been
affected and they go back to my response
to both arasawan to Rhoda grant that we
have the mvmv Alfred coming on board I
hope within the coming days and that
will provide some further resilience to
our network but I take the points that
have been made and raised and of course
any disruption to our Ferry network is
regrettable and the other point that I
know Kevin Stewart has been engaging on
is that we want to ensure that we
improve our communication improve calmax
communication with Islanders when this
disruption takes place and brief
supplementary please Jimmy Johnson thank
you the Scottish government has now
officially asked the UK Armed Forces to
step in and provide a temporary
replacement service across the coron
Narrows while this is a Highland Council
run service it highlights the lack of
resilience and the growing crisis in
Scotland's Ferry Network so can the
first Minister advise me if he was
involved in signing off that request to
the mod and if so when he did that and
given the need to ensure that this kind
of disruption and the severe impact it
has on local communities doesn't happen
again will he commit today to either he
or his new transport Minister visiting
the area at the earliest opportunity to
meet with local residents and businesses
first Minister can I just um just a
slight correction to Jimmy halcrow
Johnson's question it is our mod our
Scottish taxpayer the money of course
that helps to fund the mod so it's
important that when he talks about the
mod stepping in of course these are our
assets that Scottish taxpayers help to
contribute towards I think it's a really
important point of clarification and of
course the Scottish government has been
as helpful we've helped to facilitate
that engagement between Highland Council
we know the current Ferry is their
responsibility and the mod in fact it
was my colleague Ian Blackford the MP
for Ross Sky lokabur who has helped to
ensure that facilitation between
Highland Council between the mod and the
Scottish government so we'll do
everything we possibly can in relation
to that Maca request my understanding uh
is that there are currently initial
assessments that the mod are doing
whatever the next steps are in relation
to that process that involves the
Scottish government will be as helpful
as we possibly can and can I just also
remind Jamie how Crow Johnson it was the
the former deputy first Minister that
announced in his final budget and
Scottish government would provide full
Revenue funding to councils who run
their own Ferry services and our
officials are in very proactive
engagement with the Highland Council
about these costs and of course Kevin
Stewart would be happy of course to
visit the highlands and talk to local
community about the current Ferry
question number seven
to ask the first minister of what urgent
action the Scottish government is taking
to ensure that everyone who is eligible
for any cancer testing and screening
program is receiving their invitation on
time in light of recent reports that 13
000 women who were mistakenly removed
from the National Database are being
offered an appointment for a cervical
smear first Minister okay thank you
Swisher for raising what is incredibly
important issue indeed the national
order of the cervical screening program
is underway as a result of an incident
that was brought to our attention in
2021 where a small number of women were
incorrectly excluded from the cervical
screening program after having subtotal
hysterectomies at this final stage of
the order is precautionary it follows an
initial order in 2020 one of those women
who are considered to be at the highest
risk of being wrongly excluded at no
cervical cancers were detected as part
of that audit and the risk to
participate participants in this audit
there is very low the actual number of
patients who need to be reinstated to
the screening program obviously it won't
be known until that order there is
complete and all affected individuals
are contacted funding has been made
available particularly to GB practices
to ensure they can absorb any increase
in demand
I thank the first Minister for that
answer and I recognize the complexity of
the case and we were talking about
statistically small number but every
number is a person who will no doubt be
concerned when they receive a letter so
can the first Minister assure those with
concerns that measures are in place to
ensure similar errors are not repeated
that all those affected will be
contacted as swiftly as possible and can
he indicate what work is underway to
improve access to screening including
the introduction of self-sampling to
ensure this news does not further impact
uptake first Minister
Peter Swisher is is absolutely right
although the numbers that may be small
if you receive that later I can imagine
the impact the concern and the worry
that you have and that's why I was very
keen to reiterate that the women who
were called in the first audit were the
ones that were most at risk and if you
are receiving a letter or being asked to
come back in for screening there is
still there's low risk but that of
course there is still risk and that will
be a concern for those that receive uh
the the call up as part of the audit
Beatrice Russia is also right to ask
what we have done in relation to ensure
that this error does not occur again and
this is an error that has occurred I'm
afraid we know in the system for for
many many years so we have made
improvements
um to the I.T systems in relation to the
cervical cancer screening program we've
also improved the record-keeping process
of 14 boards have taken a territorial
boards have taken action in relation to
their audit activities and we expect the
audit to be fully completed
um in the next 12 months again we've
started with those at the highest of
risk in relation to cervical cancer
she's already mentioned some of the
initiatives that we're taking forward
but also we are seeking to do more in
relation to mobile screening units as
well which we know are particularly
important in rural remote and indeed
Island communities but I think Beatrice
pressure which is a very important Point
indeed around and the fact that we need
to make sure that screening of all
cancer cervical cancer of course
included as accessible as possible to as
many people as possible
thank you and we will now move briefly
to General and constituency
supplementaries
the first Minister will be aware of an
article in this morning's Telegraph by
conservative pure David Frost which
proposes to reduce and remove powers of
devolution and undermines this
Parliament can I ask the first Minister
how is government intend to defend the
powers of this Scottish Parliament from
unelected Tories at Westminster intent
on dismantling Devolution and does he
agree that it is for all msps from all
parties to defend this Parliament from
an attack on democracy
first minister
absolutely
Lord Frost unelected Tory Pier gave the
game away he said the quiet bet out loud
he said what every single Scottish
conservative really thinks he said he
said and I'll quote him presiding
officer not only must no more Powers be
devolved to Scotland it is time to
reverse that process he said ministers
should make it clear that every elected
they will review and roll back some of
the currently devolved Powers it's
hardly a surprise that the party that
didn't support the Scottish Parliament
now wants to dismantle the Scottish
Parliament but let me be abundantly
clear whether it's on the section 35
veto whether it's their inability to
Grant an exemption in under the ime
under the Eternal Market act whether
it's the fact they want to curtail our
excellent International Development work
or external engagement with the SNP
light Scottish government we will always
defend our democracy and we will always
defend the voice and the will of the
Scottish people
I call Rose McCall
thank you presenting officer the first
Minister will be aware of the nspcc
Scotland reports keeping the promise to
infants zero to three the report states
that in Scotland we have a baby blind
spot in the care system it also states
that despite the youngest children in
Scotland being the most vulnerable to
harm the zero to three age group can
often be overlooked which is shocking
especially when a quarter of all child
protection orders are for infants under
20 days old
it makes reference to the need to
improve support and redesign of services
to keep the promise so given the public
commitments made by the previous first
Minister what will the current first
Minister do to ensure the baby blind
spot in Scotland is removed once and for
all first Minister there's a very
important issue raised by Rose McCall
indeed and she's right to scrutinize
what the government is going to be doing
to keep the promise I made a an
Unapologetic and unequivocal commitment
in relation to this government's uh
determination to keep the promise I of
course have appointed a minister that
has responsibility for keeping the
promise and Natalie Dawn will report
directly to me as first Minister on that
particular issue so I will lay out and
we will lay out as a government in
detail what we can do at 4K experience
young people there of course has been
some legislation passed by this
Parliament on issues such as for example
sibling separation but why I heard from
care experience young people in
particular was that we need to go
further in terms of implementation of
that legislation on the ground in Rose
McCall's import right the race is the
issue of the baby blind spot as it is
referred to by nspcc and of course that
is another issue that I am determined
that we do more on so I will give as I
say an unequivocal commitment to
ensuring that this government keeps the
promise not just for babies and young
people that is important but of course
care experience is lifelong and I call
Jackie Billy Scottish hospices are
facing a perfect storm of rising staff
costs increased energy and running costs
and a tough fundraising environment they
need urgent funding to match the NHS pay
uplift so they can offer their staff the
fair wage that they deserve hospice UK
met with the first minister in his old
role as health secretary some five weeks
ago but all they have had since are
holding responses time is running out
and hospices will need to make decisions
in order to sustain their services so
will the first Minister act swiftly
indeed today and provide hospices with
the additional funding that they so
urgently need first Minister we are of
course investing a record 19 billion
pounds in our Health and Social care
system this year that's only been
possible because of the progressive
taxation that we have brought forward as
the government I will speak of course
with cabinet secretary for Health and
Social care to see what more we can
possibly do what funding we are able to
provide but every single penny of our
funding has been allocated so but look
that I understand that the the issues
raised by Jackie Bailey on behalf of
hospices UK are very very important I
value the work that hospices do right
across the country I've had personal
experience when I lost an uncle to to uh
prostate pancreatic cancer forgive me
many many years ago so I do take the
issues that Jackie billabees is very
seriously indeed and we'll look to see
what what we can do whatever we can do
to support the excellent work our
hospices do right across the country
thank you that concludes the first
Minister's questions the next item
business is the members business debate
in the name of poison chowdry and they
will now be a short suspension to allow
those leaving the chamber and public
gallery to do so before the debate
starts thank you
okay colleagues if I could again
encourage those leaving the public
gallery and on the chamber to do